for the last 15 years we've voted
consistently for lowered immigration
last year under Boris Johnson it hit net
1.1 million plus illegals and the rate
at which the illegal immigration is
going up by 2024 we're going to have
more people crossing the channel and
filling up UK hotels than British men
stormed the beaches of Normandy at D-Day
my goodness so yeah this is bad
um they've had all their promises broken
and so they've just decided right we're
not flipping our votes there's no
Alternatives so we're just not voting
and so labor are going to win by default
even though they've been utterly
incompetent yeah so so one thing I'd
also like to ask you about is you know I
can't imagine the British media is too
different from American Media with
respect to the way the Border issue is
addressed or really not addressed right
the question is always of Are We being
nice enough to people who entered our
country illegally and not should we have
borders so I'm curious what some of the
rhetoric surrounding that has been
differences similarities or if it's just
kind of the same garbage that we get
here it's similar